bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france
cet accord trouvé c'est une bonne
nouvelle pour un blazer et allemand
c'est une bonne nouvelle pour tout le
monde c'était pas évident parce que
comme vous l'avez dit jusqu'au dernier
moment il ya eu un peu un bras de fer
mais je pense que ça laisse un peu de
temps à l'argentine
et vous l'avez dit l'argentine va pas
bien du tout quatrième voire un
cinquième mois de confinement la
récession l'inflation
c'est pas la première fille d'argentine
depuis trente ans il y en a eu beaucoup
et y compris les défauts de paiement
vous avez évoqué ce qui se passe depuis
le mois de mai donc là les créanciers
privés à accepter les conditions qui
avaient été proposées par le président
argentin ça couvre qu'une partie de la
dette
66 milliards de restructurer 60
milliards de dollars sur une dette
totale de 320 il reste la dette
vis-à-vis du fmi reste à dette vis-à-vis
d'un certain nombre d'états souverains
et cetera donc pour moi le sujet reste
là sur le contenu de l'accord que
peut-on dire puisqu'on l'a dit les
créanciers avaient refusé l'offre de
buenos aires à la semaine dernière sur
le contenu qu'elle s'y retrouve un peu
c'est à dire que l'argentine va
rembourser qu'une partie de sa dette
vis-à-vis d'eux concernant ses
obligations courant montant donc le
montant facial et 2,66 milliards de
dollars et l'argentine a obtenu leur
capacité de rembourser que 53 % de ce
qui est dû également les intérêts vont
être baissés il ya un bep et un délai de
grâce d'un an au départ l'argentine
avait demandé trois ans délai de grâce
là elle a été obligée de céder un peu
donc elle va rembourser là dessus à
partir de 2021
et puis les créanciers je veux dire il
faut mieux récupérer quelque chose que
rien récupéré nous sommes dans un
contexte où les problèmes de la dette
des pays émergents
les problèmes de la dette redevienne
vraiment
cruciaux aujourd'hui compte tenu de
l'impact du corona sur l'ensemble du
monde et sur les pays émergents les pays
émergents ils sont exposés à des sorties
de capitaux
le taux de change les taux de change
c'est en train de se casser la figure
baisse donc ça veut dire plus
d'inflation donc pour l'argentine cet
accord où chacun accepte un compromis ça
va lui donne un peu de temps
il faut qu'elle se consacre à ses
objectifs domestiques sortir de
l'inflation sortir de la récession
sortir du coroner c'est le pays à ma
connaissance qui aura pratiqué le
confinement le plomb et un confinement
très longue ça a évidemment des
conséquences économiques terribles
quelles sont les perspectives pour
l'économie argentine le pays qui fait
face à un taux de pauvreté de 35% une
inflation galopante également et c'est
vrai qu'avant cet accord y avait pas
beaucoup de marge de manoeuvre pour
l'argentine puisque qui était en défaut
de paiement depuis le mois de mai ce
goûter c'est un tout petit peu de temps
pour se consacrer
je parle de l'argentine et du président
argentin s consacrée à des objectifs
domestiques il faut absolument sortir de
la récession le pays va être à -10% de
recul du pib cette année alors vous
allez dire sont pas les seuls la france
aussi bête à -10% simplement les
situations sont pas comptables le taux
de pauvreté est à 35 ou 40 % taux de
chômage également qui galope un
continent latino-américain qui peut pas
aider une économie américaine elle-même
qui va moyen donc le fmi lui-même en
avril mai lors des réunions printemps a
dit la tête de l'argentine n'est pas
soutenable
donc je pense que les créanciers privés
on en tirer la conséquence en acceptant
ce qu'on produit aujourd'hui il faudra
qu'ils passent à une chaude
en ce qui concerne la dette de
l'argentine ou vis-à-vis du fmi la
banque mondiale et et la dette
bilatérale vis-à-vis des états
souverains
j'ai pas regardé les chiffres mais
j'imagine que l'argentine elle doit
avoir aussi un peu d'être vis à vis vis
à vis de la chine
bon la chine et partout la chine et
qu'en afrique la chine et est également
en amérique latine donc il faut regarder
de près
chacun devra faire un effort alors
justement vous l'avez bien précises et
on l'a dit aussi 324 milliards de
dollars c'est la dette argentine les
créanciers certes privée interviennent
mais parler du fmi des institutions
internationales
à quoi faut-il s'attendre de leur côté
goûter le fmi- qu'on le fmi au printemps
la dette de l'argentine n'est pas
soutenable venir il faut qu'il en tire
lui-même les conséquences et il c'est
pas le moment d'imposer à l'argentine un
programme d'ajustement avec dix ans
restrictif avec une politique monétaire
sévère avec une réduction des déficits
publics je pense que nous sommes tous et
l'argentine comme nous comme nounou pays
avancés dans un contexte où à court
terme il faut il faut limiter les dégâts
de la crise sanitaire
donc je demande au fmi à la banque
mondiale ou aux créanciers publics après
les créanciers privés devront faire des
choix aujourd'hui il faut que tous les
créanciers publics ou privés fassent un
effort alors les taux d'intérêt sur la
dette commerciale la dette à l'égard des
primaires en général plus important que
les taux d'intérêt vis-à-vis du fmi mais
la bd d etat mais je venais dans les
pays riches ont quand même positif les
taux d'intérêt alors que nous en europe
pour nam aujourd'hui comme celui des
taux qui sont proches de zéro quand ils
sont pas négatifs
donc je pense qu'il faut aider leurs
chantiers et fouettées d aider
l'argentine at stake pauline ester
important et puis il faut aborder le
sujet jantine dans le contexte régional
parce qu'il est l interdépendance en
termes de commerce entre pays d'amérique
latine avec les états unis que la
solution elle peut pas venir de l'europe
où au bout de la chine
il faut aussi qu'elles viennent du
continent du continent américain
merci avant christian de boissieu je
rappelle que vous êtes vice président du
cercle des économistes est professeur
d'économie à l'université panthéon
sorbonne